Okay,
so why would Allah
use
when Muhammad really didn't do anything
haram? Why would he use that
word? What does haram mean?
It means prohibited or impermissible.
Okay, so make something prohibited for
yourself which is permissible. Right.
>> Is this Allah saying that what the
prophet
did is haram? Is this Allah saying that?
And if so, prove that.
Wait, hold on. He used the literal word
haram.
Yeah, but haram is referring to what the
prophet
did to himself. He's not calling the
action haram. Do you agree that Allah's
correcting Muhammad?
It is a correction not just for him. So
if he's
correcting him, then he did something
wrong. Correct? If he's correcting him,
then he's I got you. If he's correcting
him, then he did something wrong.
Correct?
>> Not necessarily, no. Because in Islam,
[laughter]
we make a distinction between Okay,
yeah, the two grown men freaking out.
Anyways, the reason why I'm saying this
is because Hey, Korah in the chat, man.
Amen. But both of you chill out.
Anyways, the point that I was going to
make is that there is a distinction
between Allah correcting [clears throat]
an action or Allah putting an emphasis
on a particular action not necessarily
being binding.
>> What are you talking about?
>> why Okay, listen. If you actually read
the verse, it's talking about a way that
you are absolved from oaths. So, Allah
is not saying that the action was
impermissible. Allah is emphasizing that
these types of oaths are not binding.
So, let's say for example, if I say I
have
like a
I'm speaking I'm speaking very You said
a lot. You said a lot. I'm speaking very
slowly, Logic. Okay, do you What does it
mean to correct something?
Okay.
So, if a particular action isn't
necessarily 100% in line or not binding.
>> [laughter]
>> Uh-huh. So, let's say for example, if I
take an oath and this oath isn't
necessarily binding upon me.
>> What does it mean to correct it?
>> Wait, hold on. I'm speaking specifically
in this instance. So, with regards to
this particular instance, Allah
is emphasizing that this type of an oath
is not necessarily binding upon the
prophet
Muhammad.
>> you. So, what does it mean to What does
it mean to correct something? I'm in the
middle of speaking. I'm in the middle of
speaking, Logic. Yeah, but you're not
question correctly.
>> talking to Word. I don't know why you
came up and tried to involve yourself,
Logic. We're we're all in this
conversation together. Okay, let me get
another Muslim We can all chill. I'll
bring you another Muslim. Okay, let me
get Cal. Hold on. Let me send this live
to Cal real quick. Yeah, Cal already was
in here. Let me see if he stays. No, no,
no, no, cuz you wouldn't arise him, but
it's okay. We'll get We'll get my boy
Cal. No, I was in the middle of a
conversation
when he was trying to come up. And Chris
Cal said Yeah, but the guy you were
talking to was boring, man.
I mean, I can't I can't help the for
people to who comes up. They they
request up, I talk to them.
So, who
Cal, are you here? Put a one. Put a one
in the chat, Cal, if you're But anyways,
no, no, no, no, no. I'll just text Cal.
I'll text I simply want to know what
What does it mean to correct something?
That's all I asked. And you went on
something else and on waffle fest. No,
no, no, because I'm I'm speaking
specifically in relation to the verse.
Are you not a Brazilian Muslim? The
verse is sent down I didn't ask why the
verse was sent down. I simply asked
>> I mean, I wasn't
I wasn't acknowledging you. I was
acknowledging the What does it mean to
correct something?
>> I wasn't speaking to you. I was speaking
to the host, Logic. Okay, so what does
it mean to correct something? I wasn't
speaking to you. I was speaking to the
host. Let's get back to the point.
>> to you. I'm speaking to you. Yeah, I
don't feel like talking I bet you don't.
>> [laughter]
>> It's kind of boring. Yo, what's up, Cal?
Anyways, let's go back to the topic.
Let's go back to the topic.
All right. I said
I said I keep What does it mean to
correct What does it mean to correct
something, Korah? Wait, hold on. I I
wanted to hammer in one more point with
Word because he didn't address something
with There's not There's not one more
point that you're going to hammer in
with your question.
>> Wait, one second, Logic. You came up
here and you interrupted and you
derailed
No, you derailed the conversation
between Word Hey, hey, Word, is my
question a do you If If you tell me I
asked the same question I asked her
before, though. Oh, that's interesting.
Yeah, I asked the question. I asked that
same question before.
So, we're So, we're on the same page?
That's why I asked you why
What does it mean when when Allah
corrected Muhammad? Yeah,
so the intent of the verse Yes, the
intent of the verse One second. Hold on.
Yeah, I'm I'm acknowledging the verse
and why are the Christians blaspheming
in the comments? What does it mean? Cuz
earlier you was Y'all don't be
blaspheming in the comments, y'all.
Nobody blaspheming on either side, but
regardless double talking earlier,
Korah. You said you In one place you
said that it wasn't a correction and
then you're saying it's a correction but
not really. No, I didn't say that. What
I did
No, no, no. What I did is I put an
emphasis on the fact
Logic, it's going to be okay.
Regardless, why are you attacking my
rhetoric, Logic? What does it mean to
correct something, Korah? Please answer.
>> Okay, beautiful. So, in this instance,
what Allah is doing, the correction is
that he is putting an emphasis on the
fact
Wait, no, no, no. I'm asking what a
correction is. I'm asking what does it
mean to correct something.
>> I'm giving you an example of what the
correction is.
>> an example. I want to know what does it
mean to correct something, Korah? Okay,
if a particular thing is either
inaccurate or wrong. And the inaccuracy
in this instance is the presence of an
oath that is not binding.
>> If it's inaccurate, is it wrong? 61
Wait, one second. Sorry. No, please I
can't I can't The oath was in the Yeah,
yeah, yeah. The inaccuracy in this
instance Yes, the inaccuracy
or the wrong oath in this instance is an
oath that lacks binding. I got you. When
we're talking about Wait, let me finish
responding. Hold on, Logic. Okay. So, in
Surah 61, it is putting an emphasis on
the fact Wait, hold on. Do you
acknowledge that Surah 61 verse two Can
you please not ask me another question
until you answer? Yeah, I did answer. I
already answered the question, Logic.
>> you just used other words. When you say
inaccurate, does it To be inaccurate,
does that mean to be wrong?
An inaccuracy can be used
interchangeably with wrong depending on
the context. Is there Is there any
context where something that is
inaccurate can it be correct?
Uh, no.
Okay, thank you. So, like you see how we
got to So, the oath Yeah, the inaccuracy
in this instance I don't understand So,
can we agree Wait, hold on. Can we Can
we agree that Muhammad was wrong here?
Wrong in the action, not necessarily,
but what
>> [laughter]
>> Wait, no, no, no.
Wait, hold on. And Logic, what did I say
the inaccuracy was? Wait, hold on. Let's
do a test
Wait, let's do a test and see if Logic
was tracking. Hold on.
Let's do a test and see if you were
tracking. What did I say was inaccurate?
You said that him taking the oath in
this case was inaccurate.
>> No, the oath is the inaccuracy or the
wrong
Because the oath lacked binding.
>> So, did he make a wrong oath? So, what
Allah is doing is putting an emphasis
>> Did he make a wrong oath? No, he's
making the oath is unbinding. That's the
emphasis, Logic. Wait, hold on.
[laughter] The point, Logic
for it to be binding. Wait, wait, hold
on. He's doing too much, bro. He's being
theatrical. Real quick. Real quick. I I
just want to ask a question real quick.
>> so theatrical for no reason. I I'm just
I'm being
real. Was Muhammad intending for it to
be binding?
>> [laughter]
>> Uh, no.
Allahu alam, to be honest.
With regards to whether or not the
You're asking me for someone's
intention. That's crazy, dude. Is that
Is the oath binding or [laughter] not?
Uh, an oath
isn't always binding. What is an oath
then? Is an oath agreement? And you And
you That means you're binding, you know,
um No, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no. In Islam, wait, hold on. In
Islam, an oath can be both binding and
unbinding. An example of an unbinding
oath
>> What? Okay, it seems you have a tracking
issue. You don't know what's going on,
Logic.
An example of an unbinding oath, Logic
No. Hey, Logic, calm down. An example of
an unbinding oath is for example, if I
take an oath that I'm going to do
something haram, that oath is not
binding upon me. For the reason being
that it's built off of something
impermissible. Another example of an
unbinding oath
is if I make haram for myself something
haram. One thing at a time, Korah. We're
not going to let you go waffle on a
waffle fest.
>> you examples, Logic. I'm giving you
examples.
>> one thing at a time. So, if you
personally make an oath to do something
haram, is that you Is Is that an example
of you personally binding yourself to
doing something even though it's
impermissible?
It's not actually binding. What does it
mean What does an oath? Jesus Christ is
the lord of hosts. What's the What's an
oath? What do you think an oath is,
Logic?
>> What is No, don't ask me what I think it
is because I thought it meant something.
>> action.
You're vowing to either do or not do a
particular action. I'm defining the
term,
Logic. Logic, I'm defining the term.
Logic, I'm defining the term. Notice how
I let you give your off your example?
No, you didn't. You interrupted me
multiple times. Calm down.
>> You interrupted me, Logic. Okay, so
we'll just But go ahead.
Thank you. So,
I thought that we knew what the word
oath means. But now we're talking to a
Muslim. So, now we don't know because
you're double talking.
So, please, don't ask me what I think it
is after I just asked you.
What is the definition of the word oath?
Okay, so the way that we're going to
define oath in this instance is vowing
to either do or not do a particular
action.
>> When you vow to do something, what does
that mean?
Oh my goodness. I just defined to you
the term. What does it mean to vow to do
something? Cuz you're still being vague
with the definition.
I'm saying that I will do it. That's as
simple as it's going to get, man. Very
good. So, when you say that you will do
something, is that your intention
binding on yourself to do something even
if it's haram? No, intending to do
something doesn't make oath binding
within Islam. Yeah, I understand.
>> It's about the It's about the intention.
Wait, hold on because right now, Logic,
we're doing something that you hate to
do, which is speak about fiqh. So,
within fiqh, a particular oath,
regardless of whether or not your
intention is it being binding, that
doesn't make it binding. So, if you
want, we can talk about the fiqh of this
issue because I actually brought up what
Shaykh al-Islam ibn Taymiyyah says in
Majmu al-Fatawa about these particular
oaths of you making something either
permissible or impermissible for
yourself. But, if you don't want to talk
about fiqh, we don't have to talk about
fiqh, Logic. Okay. But, I'm going to tie
this back to the argument that you're
making
and a point that I make Wait, 1 second.
I'm going to tie [clears throat] this
back to the point that I was making with
the word
>> to what you just said, though.
Wait, hold on. I'm going to tie it back
to something
>> Yeah, but you just made a point. I need
to respond to what you
>> but I I'm tying this point to something
that was
>> need to respond to what you just said.
You're going down another waffle hole.
>> I'm done speaking about
>> to You need to slow down and deal with
one point at a time. It's okay. It's
okay. It's okay. You can't keep up with
me, Logic. That's my You're not going to
shotgun this up.
>> the point back to what I was saying
about the word
>> here. Sorry. I'm not I'm not a channel
like this. You actually have to deal
with the arguments.
>> Logic, You have to actually deal with
the arguments.
>> It's okay, Logic. You're on your own
time now.
>> It is okay.
>> Logic. You can't track what's going on.
I understand that I might be speaking a
little bit too quickly for you. You
don't understand
>> what the word binding means. All of a
sudden we don't know what the word
binding
Maybe you're not understanding the words
that are coming out of my
>> know what the word binding means. We
don't know what it means to be
incorrect. We don't know what it means
to be inaccurate. Buddy, buddy, wait,
hold on. Let None of this stuff that I'm
talking about is coming from
Hold on.
It's the definition of the word
Hold on. Everybody calm down. Let's
bring it back.
f i q h
>> Little room. Let's go. Let's You don't
ever ask God, Logic, about fiqh, man.
Calm down. And never ask Never ask Cora
to define anything, man. I mean, I
defined every single You're going to get
a yes no every time you ask for a
definition. Yes, it does mean that it's
a
>> I I defined every single term that you
asked me to define, so I don't know what
you're talking about.
>> not.
Yes, I did. Yes, I did. What does it
mean to vow to do something? If I'm
making a statement that I'm going to do
X. For example, if I make the statement
that I'm going to do X and
>> example. I just need the answer to my
question. Stop trying to waffle with an
example, a fake example.
>> I A fake example? Do you have a tracking
issue or something, Logic?
>> Something that's not analogous.
>> have a tracking issue, Logic, or are you
kidding me?
>> I I can't track yes no answers.
>> tracking issue, Logic.
>> double talk, and it's hard.
>> Buddy, there's no double talking going
on. Maybe you're just not tracking the
words that are coming out of my mouth,
Logic. Define what it means when you say
an oath is when you vow to do something.
What does it mean to vow to do
something? Okay, to make a positive
statement that I'm going to do X. What
does it mean to So, if I say, "I'm going
to drink this uh this water bottle." Is
that a vow that I'm making?
Uh well, depends the way that you're
defining that. Oh my goodness. You're
seriously what
the heck?
>> but within Islam, we have a different
definition for what makes an oath
binding.
>> words don't mean anything.
>> right No, no, because we're talking
about jurisprudence right now, Logic, a
topic that you have Never discussed with
me. Double talking again.
>> on. Logic, Logic, we're right right now,
we're not talking about your definition
of Logic
Calm down.
>> vow to do something?
>> Are you asking me for your definition or
the definition within
>> I'm asking you for an objective
definition of what it means to make a
vow.
>> Islam, Logic. So, this is an internal
critique. So, if I give you a vow Excuse
me. Stop cutting me off.
>> Logic, I wasn't even speaking. Why was
she Go ahead and mute her Go ahead and
mute her word or something.
>> kidding me?
>> Because she can't She can't control
herself.
>> This guy is a slow poke. What's going
on?
>> control herself. Yeah, let's let's let
each other talk, all right?
>> No, word.
>> Let's let each other talk. She can't
control herself. She's even cutting you
off now.
>> Let's let each other talk. The mods are
muting me now, but regardless.
Okay. I didn't mute you. So, when I ask
you
When I ask you to define oath, you gave
me some vague I'll mute people, all
right? Mods, don't do it. I'm capable.
>> [snorts]
>> You give some vague definition saying,
"Oh, it's when you vow to do something."
I ask you, "What does that even mean?"
And you can't even tell me what that
mean "Oh, it depends on how you're
defining it." That's what I just asked
you. But, I'm speaking about Islamic
jurisprudence.
>> Relax so that you know how to engage
with the question, Cora. The waffle fest
is not going to help you, not on this
panel.
So, when you tell me that to to make an
oath when Muhammad makes something haram
for himself, all he's doing is making an
oath,
but it's not incorrect when you say that
it's an inaccurate oath, and you said to
be inaccurate is to be wrong, but in
this case, it doesn't mean that he's
wrong. He's making a wrong oath. You're
double talking. So, the question is when
you say making an oath is to vow to do
something, what does that mean? I don't
need any some elaborate example. Tell me
what it means. Okay, so I need some
clarification first. And the
clarification that I need is are we
speaking from an external lens? So, are
we speaking from the perspective of what
an oath is within fiqh or are we
speaking about what an oath is within
the English language? Because depending
on what we're speaking about, the
definition is going to vary. If you're
asking me
>> difference between an oath in in Islam
in in Islamic fiqh and the the actual
definition of the word? What's the
difference? Okay, so within Islam, when
you make an oath, you invoke Allah's
name, and you have niyyah, and it needs
to concern something which can conceive
possibly. So, in order for me to make an
oath within Islam, I invoke either
Allah's name or his attributes, and I
must have the niyyah that it is an oath,
and what I am making the oath about must
conceive within reality, and it must be
a future possibility. Now, all of these
stipulations would not be within the
definition of oath within the English
language because depending on the
context, the definition is going to
vary.
Was that exhaustive enough for you, or
do you want me to repeat it What's
What's the definition of the word oath?
Within Islam?
Lord have mercy.
>> Okay, so an oath within Islam is going
to be a statement where you A, invoke
Allah's name or one of his attributes,
B, have the niyyah of it being an oath,
and C, it relates to something which can
take place within reality and which is
taking place in the future. That is what
an oath is going to be within fiqh and
or jurisprudence within Islam. Is that
exhaustive enough for you, or do you
want me to repeat it a bit slower for
you, Logic?
>> I I like that. Thank you for that
example, word. Give me the big screen,
please. I'm about to bury this child.
Nice rhetoric, bro. No means No means
tell, right? No means tell, right?
>> No No means Hey, man.
>> Hey, man. Hey, man. Mark 10:18.
Mark 10:18. Yeah, here we go. Can you
read that? You want to read that? I just
defined it in fiqh. Oh my god, you're
Logic, you're a slow poke. All right.
Hold on. Before you read
>> poke. Before I have you read, I have to
have you read
>> You are a slow poke. Before I have you
read as a half-brain. You are a slow
>> not Did you not just make me
>> Logic, you are like top three sub five
intellectually. Can you do that?
>> You have sub five IQ. Calm down. Let him
Let him read. Let him Let him read.
>> Buddy, I just gave him a definition.
>> [laughter]
>> You ready now? So, notice what you did,
Cora.
Earlier, you said when I asked you to
define what an oath is, you said that an
oath in Islamic fiqh is going to be
different from the definition of the
word oath in the in our English
language. I asked you, "What is the
difference?" You haven't told me the
difference. You just gave me some waffle
fest on what you're making up about what
an oath is within Islamic fiqh, which is
to call upon God. To call upon God, make
a statement to call upon God, to bind
yourself and make a statement calling
upon God upon something that can
possibly happen in reality, and yada
yada yada. Okay. Well, let's see what
oath means in the English language.
Right here, it says a solemn, usually
formal calling upon God or a deity to
witness to the truth of what one says or
to witness that one sincerely intends to
do what one says. It's exactly what you
just said the Islamic fiqh is an an
oath. That's false. So, you just Please
be quiet. I'm I'm trying to give you the
other half of the brain.
>> [laughter]
>> So, you just buried yourself by trying
to make This This is what we do here.
What we do here is we expose how the
waffle fest is just waffle. You say a
lot without saying anything. And so, you
try to make it make up that all of a
sudden oath in Islam is different from
just the word oath in general. And it's
not any different. So, again, we see
that both an oath is a calling upon God
bearing witness about what the person
intends to do. You said that this is the
same thing that Muhammad did. Was the
oath that Muhammad made, was it a
correct oath that he made, or was his
oath wrong? Please answer simply.
Beautiful. Uh give me big screen real
quick, word.
Okay, perfect. So, he made the positive
claim that the definition that I gave
for oath was actually just a bunch of
waffle and salad that I gave him, and it
wasn't necessarily in compliance with
the definition within the English
language. Now, every single stipulation
that I gave you for the definition is
present within Islamic fiqh of fiqh.
Now, Logic, I'm going to ask you after
this to repeat all of the conditions
that I gave you for an oath within Islam
because the definition that you just
gave me from a dictionary is not
exhaustive. Buddy, I let you speak, so
are you going to let me?
Are you going to continue acting like a
kid?
>> question for me. Do Do you want me to
spell kid out for you and then repeat it
after me?
>> Logic, I have a
Don't ask me anything until you answer
the question. Logic, logic.
I'm going to respond to everything that
you said and then I'm going to answer
your question. Can you answer first
and then and then expound? I don't need
to do all that because you didn't answer
my question, but I'm going to do you No,
no, no. I'm going to do you a solid and
then I'm going to answer your question.
>> half-brain. You didn't have a question.
Okay, keep keep insulting me like the
little dog you are.
>> You You were the one that you you Oh,
now you can't take trash talk?
No, no, no. I I didn't insult you
personally.
>> talk, you know what I mean?
>> take you I didn't insult you personally
though. You did. You said I was slow.
Yeah, I called you a slowpoke.
>> Okay, so then so you can take the trash
talk, huh?
>> Regardless,
the definitions, Logic, calm down. The
definition that I gave you for Was
Muhammad's oath correct or was it a
wrong?
>> The The oath was not binding. No. I
didn't ask if it was binding. I asked
Word, did you hear my question, Word?
>> That's the correct terminology. Word,
did you hear Did you hear my question,
Word? But, the oath is not binding. It's
as simple as that. Don't Okay, so Word,
hear my question. I'll ask it again. Oh
my goodness.
>> oath that Muhammad made, was it wrong or
was it correct?
What does it mean for an oath not to be
binding, Logic? Literally, what do you
think that means?
>> [laughter]
>> Let's be smart about this, Logic.
>> Thanks for coming, Cora.
>> What does it mean for an oath not to be
binding?
Thanks for coming, man.
>> [laughter]
>> Watch your heat, Chad.
Hey, [music] hey, Logic, I have a
question.
>> [laughter]
>> Okay.
What does it mean to know in English?
Don't [laughter] give me the Christian
definition. What does it mean to know?
>> [sighs and gasps]
>> Oh my goodness. Man, he's biting out.
Come on, Cal. I don't know even know why
she brought Cal up. Cal didn't even say
nothing.
Because cuz cuz Cal's the smart one.
Yeah, he knew he couldn't
He couldn't waffle out of that.
>> [laughter]
>> Cal Cal Cal did a good job staying out
of that one.
My gosh, Cora.
You got to get better at this. You're
not ready for this, Cora. Honestly, you
got to get better at this, okay? And And
this is probably why you came on a on a
fake account so that you wouldn't get
noticed and wouldn't get chewed out by
your by your
by your handlers
who's going to then flog you for getting
dogged out by us and getting dog walked.
But my goodness, seriously, sis. You got
to do better. You got to you know, deal
with deal with the arguments directly.
Like everybody in here can see past the
fake waffle and the fluff. Saying a lot,
pretending to talk a lot. And you speak
very well. You annunciate your words
very well.
But with no You're not saying anything.
Everybody sees it.
So, you got you got to do a better job.
You'll You'll get better though. With
time, you'll you'll get better.